[Music]
[Applause]
mayor Adams wants a moment of silence so
you'll forget the drugs and violence
yeah mayor Adams is requiring all public
schools and NYC to provide students with
mindful breathing exercises every day
yeah it'll help kids develop a new
appreciation for the smell of urine
the mandated exercises evolve two to
five minutes of concentrated breathing
who knows if this helps but the teachers
of course are hoping this gets students
in the mood for sex
perverts
pervert teachers I condemn you
supporters of the practice say it lowers
stress improves mood and helps with
learning which will make the older boys
better at shoplifting and beating up the
elderly
mayor Adams has been a promoter of
meditation for a while even crediting it
with helping him get elected I wonder if
he thinks this is the school experience
of the future
this is the school experience of the
future two to five minutes think about
that we're not talking about hours two
to five minutes is a game changer
a game changer
uh maybe I'd say more cops and prisons
would be a game changer but there's new
breathing instruction along with the
city's existing School yoga program are
being hailed as the next great evolution
in education because who needs math or
reading
sorry flexible students with strong
lungs can more easily Dodge gunfire
while they're running home
Janice I actually do believe that
breathing is good for you if you don't
breathe you die right this is the
scientific fact yes why is it that he
finally cares about our kids breathing
when for two years they were masking
them up and our kids couldn't breathe
and I can't wait to get the email from
the teacher going your kids don't
breathe properly in my class
I would be you know I think I I would be
the kid in the class that would be
farting making farting noises while
everybody else is doing it right right
when it starts yes right before the
teacher says deep breaths
that's a good fart noise
[Music]
I went Foghorn you went Ripper all right
that is a funny fart worry about it
that's making it is pretty funny do it
again
no thank you everyone
people don't say we're on par with
special reports
have you ever seen him do a whole fart
look who can do a better fart noise
I imagine breathing must be hard for you
you know sleeping under old newspapers
it is but look luckily
when when uh Big Jim yeah lights the
trash can on fire oh that's nice that
the smoke really helps
I've lost my mind when I saw like New
York City has a department of like yoga
and mindfulness there's some money well
spent what is that gig pay and I tell
you who they they're gonna need to help
give like breathing lessons to these
parents who find out that the city's
gonna teach your kid to breathe yeah
right like you're gonna need that
exercise when oh the kid can't read he
can't write and you're at a bunch of
ton of money yeah and and you're just
like hmm how do I not kill the teachers
also I mean cat it's it's not a bad
thing to teach but there's an
age-appropriateness problem here kids
don't take this stuff seriously because
there's no instant gratification you
can't you you can talk to them about
money you can talk about them about
dances or food you can't talk about like
breathing they don't they're not they
think you're going to live forever yeah
yeah as someone with anxiety disorder
not to brag
um this stuff is really helpful
mindfulness breathing uh but you're
right I feel like kids probably won't
take it that seriously it's not the
worst idea it's also two minutes or
whatever and also if a school doesn't
want to do it probably be real easy to
get away with not doing it yeah someone
like checks in like oh where's the
breathing like you just missed it
we did it while you're in the bathroom
what a terrible place to breathe though
I mean cool yeah kids smell I don't know
if you remember being a kid but like I
went to an old school and that place
smelled like the worst bathroom at the
worst
baseball stadium in the ninth inning
after somebody threw up whatever
happened to like recess yeah just let
kids go outside and be kids like like
what do we
putting this right you know what this
adult BS on children your white
privilege is disgusting today uh Douglas
do they have breathing in England or is
it called something different we
actually came up with it
it was one of one of it was one of the
many gifts we gave for the world
um yeah it's actually invented in India
and you guys stole it
and your face yeah I'm not gonna get
into a colonialism argument
um no it's interesting that at the same
time the rest of the world is trying to
produce very competitive people uh we're
focusing on teaching kids to breathe
um look my worry about this is that we
should have a new rule in America that
every time anyone does anything like
this we should be intensely suspicious
of what they're not doing right like
anytime a corporation says you know
we're very big on trans by non-binary
people this month you could go we're
going to look at your books very closely
yes like we're going to look at where
you're spending the money or where
you're hiding the money we should be
very very suspicious all of this is a
way to hide something you're not doing
New York's authorities all the teaching
unions it's the same thing across this
country whenever they do this stuff like
when Randy Weingarten goes to Ukraine
why did she go to Ukraine she has no
particular peacemaking ability as far as
we know she's never fought in an armed
conflict
um uh but she goes secret we should
immediately say what are you hiding what
are you not doing in America and every
time that'll show us gold I guarantee
yeah it would hurt it's true
what's High I mean it's like talking
about breathing and and plant-based
diets is great but it it's like that's
because he can't talk about this stuff
like seven percent reading ability yeah
some districts there's nothing else it's
a crime what else can you say so we just
talk about that stuff all right we gotta
move on hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else